[Music]
[Music]
hello hello hello Bona gram it's time
for your daily [ __ ] on the
ground oh [ __ ]
just when you thought it was safe it's
another beautiful [ __ ] day in
paradise and the best thing is you are
there
you understand me you're here no more
[ __ ] worrying no more what's gonna
happen my life
it's pilot to Bombardier from Baltimore
to [ __ ] it in San Francisco we're gonna
pilot this [ __ ] [ __ ] all away
[Music]
you
I've been waiting for you [ __ ]
but I've been kind of busy all day
understand me sometimes life gets in the
way of the reef it never really does cuz
you don't me I'm always [ __ ] puffing
trying to make it happen I got stoned to
the [ __ ] DS ills this morning went on
a simple mission and a few missions the
best mission was I went to the weed
store right now as we speak from this
beautiful [ __ ] hot scorching day I
got to [ __ ] quarters Brian and that
[ __ ] car it's gonna be brittle about
four [ __ ] hours I'm hungry right now
but I don't even get the [ __ ] car
because the reefer [ __ ] get ready
it's fumigating understand me
[ __ ]
I got some of this Mickey Mouse I smoked
some one in essence and even oh [ __ ] I'm
usually not a sativa man it wasn't my
card Ryan I went to the doctor the other
day that the blood test after the
[ __ ] blood test I wanted to get my
head together before I had some Cuban
food and I rolled the join this [ __ ]
good googly moogly I got a [ __ ]
quarter and [ __ ] crying you know why
cause I'm a [ __ ] Savage it's fight
week international fight me amazing that
people from all [ __ ] over Cubans
Puerto Ricans Mexicans Brazilians Irish
[ __ ] terrorists how miss Dix
everybody's gonna [ __ ] be there you
understand but enough with the
chitty-chat a joke are we gonna spark
this [ __ ] solitude not I'm behind a
building [ __ ] sirens are going off
and I'm waiting and you're talking to me
about [ __ ] hummus dicks what the [ __ ]
let's do this
I love getting [ __ ] stoned at about
1:30 afternoon it's a beautiful thing
I'm saying pilot to Bombardier pilot to
Bombardier the monsters are in full
[ __ ] effect
[ __ ] my day is done
we gotta fight companion my main man Joe
Rogan time then I'm gonna plant the
[ __ ] Viva Las Vegas for a Showtime on
I will my main man at the KA [ __ ]
theater I think your man GM I don't even
[ __ ] it I don't give a [ __ ] on my word
about tomorrow today is the mack daddy
I'm worried about and now we're gonna
[ __ ] sling dick today that's all you
should be worried about
I bomb a [ __ ] smoking
I'll blow clouds out of [ __ ] anything
in the stamp you know why dr. beliefs is
breathing that's why you gotta get the
book you get that [ __ ] guarantee in
that size there were some IP at the end
of the pier little smoke comes out like
you shot a [ __ ] gun out of my hell
you know why W knz [ __ ] that's
why look at Joey looking dapper
they head to a [ __ ] deck
even with wrinkles and a big nose I
still got it cuts up if you know why
that's why
anyway when I got you see think I
[ __ ] tell you people [ __ ] stories
[Music]
you smell the crap fresh do we need a
yard or do you look ahead of you know if
you got [ __ ] you smell that you can
smell that [ __ ] but that comes out of
your helmet me on these the world most
comfortable [ __ ] on the way they
understand me go to me on these right
now and tell him uncle Joey attention
and then also dot
protein from on it is I'm saying I'm
[ __ ] you [ __ ] if I'm which
it I'm which I tell you what the [ __ ]
and we do it together like family got
some and forth protein I'm gonna melt
this [ __ ] fence or what effect amount
and mature men must be listen you can't
[ __ ] fat shame me if I'm doing jumping
jacks understand you can't fine you
can't [ __ ] fat shame Joey who gives a
[ __ ] about fashion like spark that's
[ __ ] Saudi absolutely right sometimes
the reason
gotta love it this is it will you mean
tell you I'm going will either come with
[ __ ] when Stefani and and the other
Mambo hanging out drinking champagne
mimosa cocktail what are you [ __ ]
nuts I don't even like that [ __ ] I see a
[ __ ] models people I run the other
way I see cameras all night with all
that [ __ ] you want to shoot me up you
got a baby a human-scale beside that or
not we could take one more
[ __ ] you can't walk down long-legged
will join now let you leave have more
mode up I want you in the best date you
can be see what attack these [ __ ]
[ __ ] the ball
you know big though I'm just trying to
take those smooth I'm right I'm gonna do
a little relaxing gotta pick the baby up
with school take it to a food truck and
then you get on the 101 and cut Asians
off like a nation you don't make you
don't [ __ ] around in boy decent down
Kumbha Mela [ __ ] pig - I look at my
cell of Kohana me I said I'm in the
wrong column from the ayah but I see - I
see it Channel
Oh Machiavelli never said it
boy hit the moon look man you no matter
to me seat I'm sorry
anyway sorry I got the [ __ ] cubed
minute end
that's that
ah yes tell you scoring at night and I'm
not no I had was afternoon inspiration
for you it's about 4:30 in New Jersey or
whether to [ __ ] you are you driving home
y'all whole hung you didn't bring that
[ __ ] join me in shame like you always
gotta have a little [ __ ] number in
the car hidden so when you get in there
before you even get in they don't
blowing in the caucus and your accessory
to the felony you blow up before you get
the code even if you gotta pull over
somebody take too [ __ ] good food to
lose you get back in the car you put on
serious [ __ ] Jim Norton the [ __ ]
Florentino [ __ ] the studio 54 and
channel 50 then you just drive with your
[ __ ] drive with a different state of
mind like that touch your [ __ ] him or
plea over the tree got his own [ __ ]
head up inside the side down pretty
[ __ ] I am happy you people dropped by
and was sitting minding my own business
you know me listen to the birds chirping
watching the [ __ ] scrounge
[Music]
you've obviously made my afternoon
better that's why I love you
[ __ ] I'm with you you would
make him there what else everybody else
can suck my [ __ ] dick okay
because that's how we do it we're not
doing nothing special but I take you to
a gin but I take it to a rest when I
show you the VIP people but I take it
backstage and have the qualms hanging
with [ __ ] now it's me and my [ __ ]
Piper players Mike them as my pipe
gently weeps that's the name of my
[ __ ] store your baked top suppers I'm
just checking in making sure you
straight you know wonderful Joey loves
you no matter what whether you're black
border Rican Chinese with one eye you
come we had okay beside that I don't
know what else to tell ya I'm gonna get
stung I'm the right
I'm gonna relax and get ready for the
[ __ ] fight to attack Perry
hopefully you'll join me if not
oh [ __ ] pilot to Bombardier pilot to
Bombardier helicopter colonel
pilot to Bombardier they're looking for
the weasel
they're looking for a [ __ ] way for
the weekend who's better than us
anyway
if you know anything about me at people
if I have things to do and people to see
okay I'll take two steps to the rim and
get out of here okay so I love you guys
be careful
always have a joint rolled into the
carpet you can hit it outside the car
and always have a pen in your top pocket
ready a step for your surance guy they
don't know that I got a [ __ ] pink to
the neck in this time anyway I love you
guys stay black uncle Joey oh yeah I'll
old people are saying it they gear the
wire stay black